Speaker 1: Dozens of you wrote to me
Speaker 3: about
Speaker 1: the neo-Nazis openly demonstrating
in Florida, in Orlando, Florida.
It is absolutely wild.
What is going on down there?
And it's another reminder that, you know,
it's it.
It pains me that among some on the left, Jews
are seen as a privileged group that is not
a minority targeted by so many different right
wing and sometimes, unfortunately, left wingers
as well.
But we should not allow that to become the
dominant perspective among the left because
it is just flat out wrong as officials denounce
Nazi rallies in Orlando.
DeSantis accuses political opponents of smear
What neo-Nazi demonstrators in Orlando over
the weekend drew bipartisan condemnations,
but Gov. Ron DeSantis remained silent until
Monday afternoon when he responded to questions
about the rallies with a tirade against his
political enemies rather than against the
neo-Nazis.
So what I'm going to say is these people,
these Democrats who are trying to use this
as some type of political issue to try to
smear me as if I had something to do with
that.
We're not playing their game.
Well, what about denouncing the neo-Nazis?
He referred to the demonstrators a group of
about 20, shouting anti-Semitic slurs while
waving Nazi flags as some jackasses doing
this on the street and said they would be
held accountable.
But he also accused Democrats, who called
for him to denounce the neo-Nazis of exploiting
the demonstrations now.
They just want you to denounce the neo-Nazis.
It's very simple.
Here's some video of this bizarre and disgusting
event.
Speaker 2: Right?
Speaker 1: Know so that was Heil Hitler and
what he did.
It's it can be hard to hear.
And if you're not watching, there's swastikas
everywhere
Speaker 2: out
Speaker 1: there doing the Heil Hitler salute
as well.
They're dressed in sort of like manner.
Is it?
Is it sort of like SS laughing?
Uh, I don't.
I don't know.
Speaker 3: All right, Paul
Speaker 1: White power shout, there
Speaker 2: are very few.
Six million viewers.
Speaker 1: So six million viewers referring
to six million Jews dead in the Holocaust
and doing the Heil Hitler salute.
Speaker 2: And right on your second point
power is when you look at
Speaker 1: white pride is when you think it
white power is when you live it.
That's another nice little phrase choked
Speaker 2: up anger your rabbi.
That's something about a rabbi.
Look at him.
Oh yes, we're you're going back to so we can
somehow push right there together.
Speaker 1: So I think that wow, that was we
can tell you as a Jew, from how close together
your eyes are.
Speaker 2: You think I'm going to go tell
somebody about that.
I the.
And I think the rabbi does.
Speaker 1: So this is the United States, folks.
This is the United States, and this is not
only demonstrations.
I think it's important that we remember that
this is the sort of cartoonish outburst of
it, but that we are continuing to see stories
like this one.
Out of Chicago synagogues vandalized and damaged
hours apart in West Rogers Park and Lincoln
Wood, multiple synagogues vandalized or damaged
just miles apart Sunday in Chicago and Lincoln.
Would someone spray painted graffiti on a
synagogue in West Devon?
VIDEO shows a hate symbol was spray painted
on the back side of the synagogue.
Someone spray painted graffiti on a cargo
container about a block away.
Hours earlier, a man was seen on video kicking
out the side window of a synagogue in Lincoln
Wood.
Unclear if the incidents are related.
And older woman Debra Silverstein said vandalism
was discovered at several local Jewish institutions
and businesses.
We want to make sure we stay on top of this
because unfortunately, I say this with peace
and love to many of my progressive brethren.
Brothers and sisters are not keyed in to the
anti-Semitism.
They write it off with some very typical sort
of Filhos Semitic tropes that I've talked
about before, and I don't want to see that.
So we're we're going to stay on top of this.
Whatever other shows do, I can't tell you,
but we're going to be staying on top of this.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P before
I play today's voicemail.
If anyone in the audience works for Rivian,
the electric car maker, please get in touch
info at David Pakman dot com.
We have we have an idea we'd like to talk
to someone from Rivian about.
So if you work at Rivian, the electric car
manufacturer info at David Pakman dot com.